you know a lot of people exercise for a
lot of different health reasons for
weight loss
for general fitness
but not a lot of people exercise to
prevent cancer or if they have cancer to
improve the outcome
i have some really interesting data that
i'm going to share with you that not
only shows an interesting connection but
why it decreases the risk for cancer is
very interesting study after study and
i'll put quite a few studies down below
shows a
major
decrease in risk of getting endometrial
cancer
colorectal cancer prostate cancer breast
cancer lung cancer ovarian cancer
gastric cancer did i mention breast
cancer i think i did so let me give you
a couple little basics to
share before i explain why exercise will
help a person number one thing you need
to know is cancer occurs from a normal
cell
somehow for various reasons the
mitochondria become damaged and then the
cell
switches flips its metabolism to the
fermentation of things like glucose so a
normal cell uses a lot of oxygen
a cancer cell in their fermentation
process
is done without oxygen so it's anaerobic
so we have a normal cell uses a lot of
oxygen
and cancer cell doesn't have to use
oxygen at all it ferments things now
another difference between a normal cell
and a cancer cell
is that a normal cell has
a lot of mitochondria in a cancer cell
there's not a lot of mitochondria okay
those are damaged or
not working a normal cell has a limited
lifespan okay i can't live forever and
one way that the body does this is
through something called apoptosis which
is controlled cell death where your
cells commit suicide
so they don't don't keep growing in
cancer cells
they don't get the signal to create
apoptosis so they keep living on and on
and on so that's what apoptosis is it's
controlled cell death a normal cell gets
this trigger
and that trigger
comes from
a certain type of byproduct from the
mitochondria okay and it's a byproduct
from using oxygen okay and that
byproduct is called
ross okay stands for reactive
oxygen species with an s it's a group of
several reactive chemicals
that influence our bodies a certain way
and it reacts to the body
and the reaction that i want to talk
about is in its ability to trigger
apoptosis
so ross
triggers the cells to commit
suicide in cancer cells you have a
deficiency of ross in normal cells you
have an abundance of ross
so to make this really simple
the more oxygen that you can give
your cells the more ross or reactive
oxygen species that you have to trigger
apoptosis
this is why things that have low oxygen
enhance
cancer okay like smoking for example
you're decreasing oxygen in the body
like an infection that's a low state of
oxygen in the body like inflammation
okay why do you think cancer invades
areas of inflammation
because there's less ross to trigger the
apoptosis and it can grow more this is
another reason why cancer tends to grow
in areas of old injury too and if
someone's smoking and irritating the
lungs
that would be like micro trauma now in
chronic stress states you have a lowered
amount of oxygen in a high glucose state
so if someone's a diabetic
or maybe they're consuming a lot of
carbohydrates and running on their
bodies on sugar or carbs that's a lower
oxygen state
than
a state where they're burning uh ketones
or your fat but this next thing is very
interesting
why is it that
when they do research on
synthetic
antioxidants like beta carotene and
alpha tocopherol which is vitamin e or
the synthetic versions
of these vitamins that there is an
increased risk of cancer could it be
that these synthetic
antioxidants or antioxidant
chemicals
lower the oxygen thereby lowering the
apoptosis in cancer cells well i think
that's really what occurs because in the
studies that show that these
antioxidants worsen cancer
they always use synthetic they don't use
the natural
version and so it's important to
understand this because if you have
cancer
or you want to prevent cancer there are
things that you can do to
slow things down or hopefully prevent
things okay number one you know get on
the ketogenic diet of course get your
your dietary sugars weighed down maybe
you want to do the hyperbaric oxygen
chamber okay that's one thing you could
do now this is something i'm not
recommending but the way that several
chemotherapies work and even radiation
is that they increase
more ross okay
which then creates apoptosis in the
cancer cell but the problem is it comes
with the package and creates a lot of
other collateral damage and side effects
but one of the biggest things that will
increase oxygen and ross is
exercise simple exercise exercise
increases your oxygen by 10 to 20 times
and it can increase ross by a thousand
times so this is just another reason
to exercise to prevent cancer and again
if you have cancer you should be
exercising just flooding your body with
oxygen this is going to increase the
byproduct ross which will help create
apoptosis to the cancer cell i've done a
lot of videos on cancer but this is
another little thing that you can add to
the protocol plus exercise also improves
your blood sugars and insulin resistance
okay which will then decrease the risk
of getting cancer from another angle
because people that have insulin
resistance obesity
are at a higher risk level for getting
cancer also if you're exercising outside
you get the vitamin d
vitamin d has been known to decrease the
risk of getting cancer as well as a
certain amount of sun rays like the
infrared spectrum i'm not talking about
burning yourself i'm talking about
getting a dosage of sun that's not too
much just a moderate amount
so you don't let yourself get burned the
other thing the exercise will do is
increase the number of mitochondria okay
because when cancer cells you just don't
have enough mitochondria to produce the
oxygen and the ross and lastly exercise
will improve your immune system the very
thing to help fight off cancer because
there's two types of cells in the immune
system that directly
kill
cancer cells now for more information
about what to eat
for cancer
watch this video right here
you